good morning Hank it's Tuesday so next
month I'm going on a brief tour with nat
wolff shailene woodley and Ansel Elgort
who played respectively
Isaac hazel and Gus in The Fault in Our
Stars movie and people get to decide
where we're going and I have to remember
to talk about that but first I want to
talk about prisons boy today's video is
gonna be funny Hank a lot of times when
we talk to nonprofits about outreach
they're like we're gonna make a guy for
poop on a stick because clean water is
important and poop is funny and your
audience will like that because you guys
are funny and I'm like hey I think you
mean Jif or gif I mean words belong to
their users but guy fizz's stretch and
be I don't think that funny stuff
actually works people just want you to
talk about what you care about it's not
like we rely on pratfalls to get laughs
or whatever anyway I've lost a thread I
really liked your video about prison -
they're a couple - go the hell oh that
actually turns into a very painful
pratfall that better have been funny
right anyway I really liked your video
about prisons it spurred some
interesting discussions I wanted to add
a couple things first there was a lot of
talking comments about the role of race
and sentencing and the data there is
pretty overwhelming in the u.s. a 2013
study by the US Sentencing Commission
found that African Americans on average
received sentences 20% longer than white
people who committed similar crimes also
they found that that disparity is
actually increasing socioeconomic class
is also a big factor in sentencing and
the question of length of sentence
brings me to one other point I want to
make sure capita a bunch of European
countries actually admit more people to
prison per year than the US does but
their sentences are much shorter and
that's one of the big reasons we have
the highest incarceration rate in the
world it isn't that we sent in so many
people to prison it's that we sentence
them to prison for so long and in the
u.s. that's driven largely by long
sentences for drug offenses I put some
links in the doobly-doo for those who
are interested all right moving on to
JPS movie stuff so quick ketchup ink I
wrote a book called The Fault in Our
Stars which by the way comes out in
paperback today that's probably what I
should have made my video about but
whatever I wanted to talk about prisons
and guys apparently anyway the movie
adaptation of The Fault in Our Stars
comes out June 6 but like the hullabaloo
and travel leading into the movie starts
for me like now and as part of that
hullabaloo Ned and Ansel and Shailene
and I are going to be visiting several
places around the u.s. doing I don't
really know what yet but it will be fun
I'm sure and Fox is letting people
choose where we go based on tumblr notes
for various states so you can go to the
link in the doobly-doo find your state
like and reblog it and that counts as
like two votes for your state now Hank
you would think and I think
Fox probably thought that the votes
would line up according to the
population of each state but at least so
far know there are some very
well-organized small states which is
awesome because I would like to visit
North Carolina
anyway selfishly Hank I want
nerdfighters to decide where we go so
nerdfighters if you don't mind go like
and reblog your state on the tumblr with
it
Oh apparently if not called the tumblr
Hank it's just tumblr now I grow old
Hank I grow old I am literally wearing
the bottoms of my trousers rolled I
think I don't even know what this video
is about today like what do you call the
video like this tiffy owes prison movie
I just had a great idea for a movie all
right Hank I have to drop everything and
go right Mike if he owes prison movie
screenplay I'll see you on Friday